how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything
relating to the mcu and today we have
some good news in regards to marvel's
phase four
and two black widow now sadly we were
already supposed to get the black widow
film
it was originally supposed to come out
at the end of april or beginning of may
depending on where you lived in the
world but due to coven 19 they had to
push it back to november
which of course was upsetting but at
least it wasn't pushed back another year
but like i said we have some good news
today because not one but
two new black widow trailers are coming
and i'll tell you when to expect them in
this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the mcu and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a black panther funko pop
to enter all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and leave
a comment down below
so yes we are getting two new black
widow trailers and i'll tell you how
that was discovered
a new black widow trailer was classified
today and thanks to twitter user jensen
coleman for digging up the evidence on
this we know that it's true
it is confirmed and based on the listing
from the british board of film
classification the bbfc
the new trailer is said to be around 2
minutes and 38 seconds
and it has a rating of 12 a which means
it is suitable for fans who are 12 years
and older
now this is a pretty long trailer it's 2
minutes and 38 seconds
that's really long especially if you
consider the fact that marvel studios
supposedly already gave us their what
they called
final trailer but apparently that wasn't
the final trailer and apparently this
isn't the final trailer either
it seems that another trailer has been
classified for black widow and this
trailer is around 1 minute
and 44 seconds and it's under the same
12a rating
now what does this mean well san diego
comic-con
is coming up this month this would be a
perfect opportunity for marvel studios
to show a little bit of new footage
about black widow and then release it to
the public not too long after
now it hasn't been confirmed that marvel
studios will be attending
sdcc at home and in fact there's a lot
of talks right now that marvel studios
could simply do their own type of comic
con event
much like dc is doing their own fan dome
event where they can show exclusive
content
and this would honestly probably be
better because here at their own event
they could do whatever they wanted to do
and they could set their own time limit
to talk about whatever they wanted to
talk about
not only could we get a new two and a
half black widow trailer but we could
also get official teasers for the falcon
and the winter soldier and the wanda
vision series and perhaps even the loki
series
and the big one that everybody's been
waiting for the eternals so it would
almost be better if marvel did have
their own event
but let's not also forget that black
widow when it comes up in november is
going to need some marketing again
so these trailers could have been
created because black widow is only 5
months away now and as we get closer
they could release the one and a half
minute trailer and then when we get
right next to november they could
release the
final two and a half minute trailer now
there's going to be new footage in these
trailers but it's probably going to be a
mix of new footage and of course old
footage
just some new footage to get fans
excited for the release of black widow
when it comes out in november
hopefully so we're getting two new black
widow trailers let me know how excited
you are about this
in the comments down below and would you
like marvel to do their own event or
would you like them to appear at san
diego comic con
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating to the mcu
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof